[Music]  hi I'm Natalie Dormer and I'm here today  doing a shoot with GQ where's the best  place to pick someone up New York City  I'm really happy today but to be here in  New York City in some pretty hot men  walking around Brooklyn I have to say my  first date was very sweet very innocent  just holding hands you know when you're  both a bit awkward and you don't really  know what to do with yourself  [Music]  do I have an intimidating face not many  men come up to me and give me one liners  [Music]  the best game of Thrones character on a  date would be the new improved Jamie  Lannister the worst person to be in a  relationship with or go on a date with  with would probably be King Joffrey of  Westeros so I'm completely screwed my  biggest misconception with men growing  up was men need as much TLC as as women  do  [Music]  [Music]